[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález el canal de
la mancha que separa a las islas
británicas de europa continentales el
nuevo punto de tensión y de disputas
entre el reino unido y francia- ante el
aumento en el número de emigrantes que
intentan cruzar las aguas del canal la
mayoría de ellos parten del puerto
francés de cale e intentan navegar hasta
las costas británicas cerca de la ciudad
de dover se trata de una distancia de 33
kilómetros en el punto más estrecho del
canal y también uno de los pasos
marítimos más transitados de europa
precisamente el tránsito de migrantes
por este canal y canal de la mancha se
ha incrementado exponencialmente en los
últimos meses sobre todo desde que el
reino unido- abandonó la unión europea
demos un vistazo a las cifras en lo que
va del 2021 año que ya está
prácticamente en su recta final unos 31
mil 500 migrantes intentaron cruzar de
francia al reino unido de manera
irregular unos 7.800 fueron rescatados
por guardacostas de ambos países
lo que preocupa a las autoridades es que
ante el aumento también están aumentando
al aumento de llegada de migrantes
también están aumentando entonces las
muertes los accidentes y también se ha
incrementado incluso la cifra ha llegado
un punto que ya ha logrado romper
algunos récords veamos el comparativo
para evidenciar la magnitud de esta
crisis en lo que va del 2021 41
inmigrantes murieron ahogados en su
intento por llegar al reino unido para
construir un futuro mejor en el 2020 la
cifra ascendía a 7 personas fallecidas y
dos más desaparecidas y en el 2019 unos
cuatro migrantes murieron ahogados en el
canal de la mancha también en su intento
por alcanzar las costas británicas
cuáles son los motivos para el
incremento de la llegada de migrantes en
su intento por llegar al reino unido- es
una travesía que los obliga a poner a
sus vidas en peligro porque parís y
londres no logran ponerse de acuerdo
aparecen más las discrepancias en todos
los temas en todos los temas que unen a
londres y en parís se les está saliendo
de las manos el tema migratorio no
solamente al reino unido- de a francia
sino también a la unión europea que aún
no logra consolidar una política
concreta y tiene múltiples frentes con
crisis similares por ejemplo entre polón
y belarús en el mediterráneo en el egeo
lo vemos en diferentes partes del
continente también en la isla italiana
de lampedusa muy cerca a las costas de
áfrica y la isla de lesbos en grecia
ahora un reino unido- alejado de
bruselas como puedes sortear esta
situación como bruselas puede responder
y como parís también puedes responder
muchas preguntas quedan sobre la mesa
por eso la crisis migratoria en el canal
de la mancha es nuestro tema de debate
en france 24 para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a alexandra castro franco
doctora en derecho de la universidad
parís 2 es investigador y consultora en
asuntos migratorios nos atiende desde la
ciudad de parís en francia también está
con nosotros francisco rey es codirector
del instituto de estudios sobre
conflictos y acción humanitaria se
encuentra en la ciudad de madrid en
españa y en el estudio de france 24 nos
acompaña indico szeged y moza que ella
es doctora en sociología jurídica e
instituciones políticas es experta en
temas de la unión europea y de
cooperación internacional también es
directora de la maestría de derecho
económico de la pontificia universidad
javeriana de la ciudad de bogotá en
colombia ustedes nuestros televidentes
también pueden participar en el debate
con sus comentarios y todas sus
preguntas también lo pueden hacer a
través de nuestras redes sociales no se
encuentran en facebook también en
instagram también no se encuentran en
twitter estamos como france24 guión bajo
ese y arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo nuestra etiqueta
es numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas
comienzo entonces
alexandra en la ciudad de parís
preguntándole por sus por su opinión
porque se está dando este incremento en
el número de emigrantes que están
tratando de cruzar de europa continental
hacia el reino unido a través del canal
de la mancha para poder entender el
inicio de esta crisis migratoria y esta
crisis allí en el canal
hola buenas tardes para ustedes bueno yo
quisiera empezar diciendo que no estamos
en estricto sentido frente a una crisis
migratoria lo que está en crisis como
quizás lo advertía una frase que
mencionamos anteriormente es la política
de gestión migratoria de la unión
europea y esto es simplemente una
manifestación más de esta grita está
fracaso en esta política que se ha
enfocado casi que obsesivamente hacia la
restricción a las canales legales
regulares de migración hacia la
externalización de los controles
migratorios y ha fracasado en el intento
en todos sus frentes como ya lo
mencionábamos
tanto en el mediterráneo' como las
fronteras occidentales y orientales de
la unión europea este fracaso en esta
política lleva entonces a considerar que
entre más restricciones a la migración
legal se interpongan pues va a ser más
protegida la unión europea y en la
práctica se demuestra que ante la
ausencia de canales legales de migración
pues los migrantes siguen intentando
acceder a sus países de destino y que
las políticas de externalización de
control migratorio como la que sucede y
opera en el canal de la mancha entre
francia y el reino unido- pues fracasan
y de esta manera los migrantes no tienen
nombre alternativa puedes tomar estos
canales irregulares poniendo en riesgo
su vida
esto me preguntaba qué opino yo sobre
esto que está sucediendo pues tal como
ha sucedido como se publicaba hoy en el
mundo en una carta abierta que ha sido
enviada por más de 100 académicos
franceses la culpa desde los estados y
es la que es lo que se menciona aquí en
francia por parte de organizaciones de
la sociedad civil es la culpa de los
estados en primer lugar porque ya se ha
demostrado que estas embarcaciones
pidieron ayuda que esta ayuda no quiso
ser dada ni por autoridades francesas ni
por autoridades británicas en segundo
lugar porque se trata de una crisis
anunciada no es digamos es se trata de
una situación precaria desde los mismos
campamentos que se dan en francia y la
claro vibrar las autoridades franceses
frente a estas personas entonces de que
porque sea este aumento pues una es una
manifestación de las políticas
migratorias
que han puesto en marcha la unión europa
desde hace muchos años
y por qué pues dentro del afán
desesperado de las personas por llegar a
destino pues solamente tienen la
posibilidad de optar por hacerlo de
manera irregular francisco en la ciudad
de madrid su punto de vista sobre este
esta llegada masiva de migrantes que lo
que está sucediendo porque
específicamente hacia el reino unido ya
vemos también que la unión europea lo
hemos dicho tiene diferentes puntos
críticos a lo largo de sus fronteras si
desde una perspectiva general buenos
buenos días hay algunas noches casi acá
compartiría bastante lo que ha dicho
alexandra pero me gustaría añadir
algunos elementos coyunturales que creo
que son importantes las citado tú antes
el tema del break sit y eso creo que la
salida de el reino unido- federal en
europea está teniendo muchos impactos en
esto porque yo creo que el reino unido
siempre fue muy singular y no se adhirió
besarle al convenio de schengen y otros
acuerdos pero creo que esa salida ha
hecho que todavía
he reducido respeté menos ciertas normas
internacionales que tienen que ver con
estos temas en segundo lugar recibo creo
que hay que reconocer que han cambiado
también los los patrones migratorios y
en la propia covilhá ha hecho que el
aumento de los controles sobre los
camiones y sobre las entradas por el
túnel haya sido más controlados que
antes y eso ha hecho que los propios
traficantes estén proponiendo estas
rutas alternativas por por mar y eso
creo que hay que reconocerlo
es lo que explicaría este aumento tan
grande de las cifras de pequeñas
embarcaciones que quieren cruzar el
estrecho
y creo que hay que añadir también que el
atractivo que el reino unido tiene para
ciertos
demandantes de asilo y ciertos migrantes
de ciertos países es enorme y hay que
ser consciente de que los inmigrantes de
habla inglesa de yemen siria afganistán
van irán es evidente que han querido
siempre entrar en el reino unido porque
además del reino unido tiene un cierto
atractivo mayor y ya finalizó con el
mensaje de intervención que es el tiene
un porcentaje de reconocimiento de asilo
más alto que otros países europeos en el
pasado hay que reconocerlo y también
tiene una mayor facilidad para conceder
permisos de trabajo a los demandantes de
asilo de los refugiados la cosa que no
sucede en otros países europeos este
conjunto de factores coyunturales creo
que explicarían el aumento en las
últimas semanas un factor importante ahí
el factor lingüístico muchos de estos
migrantes hablan inglés y para ellos es
más fácil tratar de insertarse en la
sociedad británica que la de otro país
europeo por desconocer el idioma el
inglés es un idioma mucho más conocido
por muchos de ellos y lee con quien él
está en el estudio de france24
bienvenida buenas noches comienzo por
preguntarle su opinión sobre este tema
sobre este incremento en las últimas
semanas y estas muertes que hemos visto
a lo largo de los últimos días allí
tratando de cruzar el canal de la mancha
para luego darle paso a la siguiente
pregunta ya un poco más de tema político
mira lo más triste es que cuando a
tiempo se mueren 27 personas nosotros
ponemos la atención porque a tiempo se
murieron 27 personas pero como los
colegas están compartiendo desde europa
es que es ese cada mes que las personas
se están muriendo y no solamente en la
canal de la mancha pero pero en todas
las frutas pues por españa a ustedes
pues tienen como todas estas rutas
también entonces es es un tema muy
triste que nosotros seriamente ponemos
la atención cuando cuando tantas
personas a tiempo están muriendo y fie
sé que es muy interesante que hoy está
empezando su visita el papá francisco
en chipre y easy y específicamente
bailar es wood y hace llamado hace un
llamado donde quiero conectarme mucho a
nuestra colega en en parís donde donde
dice es que realmente ustedes lo que
están construyendo son muros ustedes no
están construyendo soluciones eso no es
sin
razón porque al papá hace esta visita
además ya anunció que va a llevar 50
refugiados desde el esbozo otra vez al
vaticano con el claro además que chipre
es un lugar particular es un país
dividido una isla dividida y hay una
zona neutral bajo jurisdicción de
naciones unidas donde hay represados
muchos migrantes que entraron a través
del lado turco chipriota intentando
intentando llegar al lado grecochipriota
que es unión europea y se quedaron en
esta zona que es una zona de nadie es un
territorio en una línea que divide al
país en donde nadie tiene jurisdicción y
se quedaron ahí y allí están viviendo
condiciones muy difíciles indicó pasó a
preguntarle antes de que hablemos del
tema general de bruselas y unión europea
francia y reino unido- ha habido
intercambio de acusaciones parís londres
señalamientos entre marco y johnson
diciendo de quién es la responsabilidad
este intercambio entre los dos países es
la altura para discutir este tema tan
complicado esta
crisis migratoria que se está dando allí
se le está dando la importancia
necesaria por esta razón yo dije que es
tan triste porque cuando uno ve este
debate entonces es una cosa que diga
macrón que eso no es la forma de una
carta abierta o por tweet para enviar
los mensajes por parte de boris johnson
pero por otro lado uno también hace la
pregunta es que realmente se preocupan
por los refugiados por los migrantes
refugiados como quieres llamar
dependiendo de la situación y realmente
lo que hay es esta lucha tan fuerte lo
que hay hoy en día entre francia y el
reino unido- es a tiempo
geopolítico es a tiempo
hay cruces a tiempo break si estás a
tiempo pues quienes van a pescar
entonces pues hay tantísimas preguntas y
cuando uno dice es que acá estamos
hablando de seres humanos en sufrimiento
y realmente de veras de este debate lo
que vemos es una lucha gigante entre
estos dos países lo que genera mucho
daño en todos los aspectos lo que uno
puede imaginar en el mundo claro
alexandra en la ciudad de parís
hemos visto los intercambios entre los
dos mandatarios entre el presidente
macro ni el primer ministro johnson y el
reino unido- proponía un a través de
'twitter' además ni siquiera
directamente a través de cancillerías oa
través de ministros oa través de
funcionarios sino a través de twitter le
propuso a francia cinco puntos
particulares para empezar a hacer frente
a esta crisis allí en aguas del canal de
la mancha de estos cinco puntos y de
esta forma particular del reino unido-
de presentar sus propuestas su opinión
bueno yo creo que viendo la forma y
viendo estando muy de acuerdo con mi
compañera en estudio la manera como se
ha manejado esta atención es casi como
una pelea entre dos ex novios
son situaciones diplomáticas que se
manejan como lo decía usted a través de
'twitter' sugiriendo mayor o menor
control sugiriendo sobre todo esto se
gira alrededor de un acuerdo que tienen
desde el 2004
francia y reino unido- un acuerdo para
la externalización de sus controles
migratorios y es en virtud de este
acuerdo que digamos que francia a dejar
pasar estas personas es decir no la
retiene y expulsar el territorio francés
estas personas se terminan instalando en
la frontera para luego intentar cruzar
al reino unido- entonces dentro de las
negociaciones se establece estas obras
sobre todo vemos presente ese mismo
énfasis que tiene europa continental en
la gestión migratoria y es el énfasis
del control migratorio
entonces más controles migratorios
mientras que por un lado se hace siempre
énfasis y quise hacerlo más doloroso de
esto es que cada vez que digamos sucede
esto más que hay que recordar que más de
50 mil personas del 93 han muerto
intentando llegar a territorio europeo y
digamos en allí en que le han muerto más
de 300 personas desde el 99 entonces hay
que tener en cuenta que que siempre se
habla del problema de los traficantes de
inmigrantes entonces uno de los puntos
en los que siempre se hace énfasis es
que hacemos con los traficantes de
migrantes hay que luchar contra los
traficantes de frentes cuando en
realidad el punto el eje debería ser qué
pasa con los canales regulares de
migración y es allí donde quizás están
levantando más voces aquí en francés
diciendo necesitamos presionar al reino
unido para que genere canales regulares
de migración aumente los canales
regulares de migración de tal manera que
las personas no tengan que volcarse
hacia la migración irregular como
mecanografía de masas se tocan dos
puntos importantes que vamos a
desarrollar más más adelante y es el
tema de los traficantes y las leyes que
tiene el reino unido- atrás el break sí
como puede armar un marco legislativo un
poco más robusto para hacer frente a
este tipo de situaciones francisco en la
ciudad de madrid aquí vemos un escenario
parecido que se repite en diferentes
puntos de europa es como el mismo guión
de la misma película pero con un
diferente acento y con un diferente
idioma vemos un país que deja pasar los
migrantes puede ser un ejemplo turquía
dejándolos pasar a grecia grecia los
retiene y los devuelve y turquía se
empieza a quedar con ellos lo mismo lo
vemos en belarús y polonia belarús los
deja pasar
polonia lo retiene y los devuelve aquí
vemos lo mismo francia lo deja pasar el
reino unido- los devuelve y el reclamo
de londres y dentro de estas propuestas
que sea el primer ministro johnson es un
acuerdo bilateral con francia sobre las
devoluciones que todos los que sean
capturados en altamar sean regresados a
francia pero francia dice a mí no me
corresponde hacerme cargo de todos ellos
porque yo también ya tengo una carga con
migrantes bastante grande que he
recibido dentro del marco de lo que me
ha pedido bruselas cómo romper este
círculo vicioso
pues yo creo que hay varias
consideraciones importantes una es que
toda la unión europea y no solo francia
está queriendo externalizar sus
controles migratorios y a un precio muy
alto el caso más relevante pues es el de
turquía que desde la mal llamada crisis
de los refugiados desde el año 2016 y
tiene acuerdos con la unión europea por
los que no deja pasar tan fácilmente
sino que se está convirtiendo en un
verdadero escudo para que no lleguen y
que lleguen solamente unos pocos
demandantes de asilo son migrantes al
esbozo al resto de islas griegas y esa
misma política está intentando hablar
europea para la crisis en afganistán y
en una menor medida porque las cifras
son buenos son inferiores es lo que
desde españa o italia se ha estado
intentando con libia con marruecos
a través de cooperación económica o de
otras medidas pero esto es una parte del
problema sólo de lo más relevante y creo
que lo comparto con las dos compañeras
intervinientes es la falta de respeto
por parte de la unión europea en su
conjunto de la convención de derechos de
los refugiados del año 1951 y de las
fueron los propios acuerdos que la unión
europea ha ido viendo conviene recordar
que en el año 2016 y muy alentado por la
presidenta todavía merkel se firmaron
unos acuerdos para que cada país de la
unión europea asumiría ciertas cuotas de
estos refugiados cosa que no se cumplió
y bueno y fue alemania la que
adoptó un respeto más estos acuerdos y
lo último que citaba sí creo que es muy
muy relevante porque ahí también se está
incumpliendo el derecho del mar el
derecho del mar en tanto en el
mediterráneo como en
o con otros lugares que se estén
cumpliendo porque el derecho del mar
establece en la obligación de los barcos
que por ahí pasan de recoger a las
eventuales víctimas y no reconoce ese
derecho de devolución al país de origen
que ahora reclama el reino unido
eso es una discusión jurídica que tal
vez supera es un debate de este tipo
pero me parece que hay que defender los
marcos jurídicos que el reino unido esté
o no esté bien a menudo que se ha
firmado y ratificado
y exigir su cumplimiento y a francia
también en este caso a seguir no creo
que no ganamos mucho y culpabilizando a
una u otra parte porque en esta crisis
creo que ambos países tienen bastante
responsabilidad y dijo aquí en el
estudio de france 24 el tema migratorio
se le está saliendo de las manos a la
unión europea no ha logrado consolidar
un marco
legal robusto que haga frente a la
situación vemos las discrepancias que
hay entre los 27 países unos países que
definitivamente no quieren recibir por
su carga económica lo que puede recibir
en cuanto a migrantes país ese tipo
eslovenia o croacia o hungría la
república checa pero otros que sí están
un poco más abiertos con condiciones
suecia de noruega up que no es unión
europea pero pero entra algunas veces
allí a ofrecer algo de la ayuda que se
puede decir de la actual de bruselas yo
creo que nosotros vemos la unión europea
muchísimas veces
muchísimo más unida que lo que realmente
es en qué sentido realmente lo que es
asunto europeo nosotros la encontramos
en los tratados que establecen y el
manejo de la unión europea y adentro de
eso no encontramos el asunto que sea una
política común de la unión europea lo
que sería el tema de de asilo
eso significa aquí que son con base de
unos tratados más que algo relacionados
con derechos humanos
y reconocimiento de derechos humanos se
habla en la unión europea y unos
directivos y etcétera lo que más que
algo desde desde principios del siglo 21
está desarrollando la unión europea
entonces tenemos como una legislación
hoy en día adentro de la unión europea
es una cosa lo que es la legislación
por otro lado entonces cuando cuando uno
habla sobre el tema de migraciones
obviamente es un tema y uno mismo
y en este caso como tú dices algunos
países entonces económicamente pueden
tener más necesidad para recibir a estas
personas que otros y en eso es algo muy
interesante porque económicamente en
este momento podríamos demostrar que en
el reino unido para recibir algunos de
estos peces pues ni grandes podría ser
bastante interesante
económicamente después de break sheet
pero bueno esto tiene una parte política
también porque es una cosa la regulación
otra cosa que económicamente como maneja
un país otro entonces pero el otro
políticamente no podemos olvidar que
están preparándonos para elecciones de
boris johnson busca su reelección en el
reino unido y el precedente marrón está
en lo mismo y el tema de migrantes es un
tema político tan fuerte y da tanta
fuerza por un lado boris johnson dice
pues mirando mi maravilloso break shit
entonces como yo puedo mantener a los
migrantes fuera del reino unido y por
otro lado más creo en lo que está
diciendo es que te mira me lo voy a
tomar ahorita a una posición más fuerte
porque reconozco ahí está una
ultraderecha pero subiendo como locos
entonces veces es este tema de por un
lado regulación por otro lado el tema
conozco y portarse al lado este tema
político eso es muy difícil navegar en
todo eso llamar a algo como europa a ver
si cuando en el caso de francia que ha
tenido episodios de ataques terroristas
y que han estado ligados a algunos
migrantes algunas personas que han
llegado de otros países a francia y
empiezan a mezclarse ahí también esa
perspectiva por parte de los ciudadanos
que dice no quiero más migrantes en mi
país porque esto relacionado con esto en
cierto punto y yo mejor lo mantengo a
raya y empiezan a aplaudir ese tipo de
políticas que decidir alexandra de ese
marco de la unión europea que no logra
entrar que no logra consolidarse en el
tema migratorio y de lo que puede hacer
el reino unido ahora que está lejos de
bruselas independiente digámoslo así con
su propia legislación qué postura puede
tomar en el marco migratorio
bueno digamos que yo diciendo de aquello
de que el marco europeo no logra
consolidarse si existe un marco y el
marco de la externalización de los
controles migratorios las devoluciones
en caliente lo que pasa es que es un
marco que fracasa entre su intento
porque parte de una premisa y es evitar
a todo costo la migración y la migración
es un fenómeno natural al ser humano y
los humanos van a seguir encontrando
cómo emigrar entonces más que ser algo
que no se consolida yo creo que es algo
que fracasa si no tengamos en cuenta la
cantidad de recursos que invierte la
unión europea por ejemplo en el frontex
para digamos para vigilar sus fronteras
externas y cómo termina el frontex
involucrado incluso en asuntos de
derechos humanos
y entonces
entonces este si es si existe un marco
que fracasa que podría hacer el reino
unido pues dependiendo obviamente de
cómo lo decían antes al estar muy
vinculado al manejo de la gestión
migratoria con cuestiones políticas pues
obviamente dependerá de la política que
quede en las próximas elecciones es
decir de él discurso político que se ha
acogido en las próximas elecciones y es
quizás lo más paradójico cierto que los
derechos humanos dependan al final de
quien sea el que esté a cargo de un país
pero a ustedes mencionaron hace un
momento como boris johnson tiene una
política digamos que se ufana decir que
gracias al presi evita la inmigración
pero recordemos que justamente con las
con las cuestiones del cobi a él le tocó
salir a mencionar que habían sido
migrantes que no habían lo sabían no
habían cuidado durante su convalecencia
en el hospital y está demostrado como
específicamente en un escenario como el
de coronavirus pues han sido en gran
parte emigrantes o extranjeros quienes
han subido en mano de obra labores
necesarias para el mantenimiento de
varios países de europa y del mundo en
general entonces yo creo que estando en
un escenario tan coyuntural cierto en un
escenario de post pandemia
digamos que mi esperanza es que los
estados de alguna manera también
empiezan a tener en cuenta la necesidad
de esa mano de obra extranjera la
necesidad de esos migrantes y empiezan
también a escuchar de alguna manera
aquellas voces de quienes dicen
necesitamos que esa política europea
recuerde esas obligaciones en materia de
en materia de derechos humanos recuerden
esos tratados internacionales que esos
mismos países impulsaron a la hora de
ser ratificados entonces es difícil
saber qué opción va a tomar el reino
unido- dependerá de la coyuntura
política pero están esas opciones claro
no y el reino unido necesita migrantes
lo veíamos hace unos meses la crisis de
abastecimiento de combustible porque no
había conductores para los camiones para
surtir las diferentes estaciones de
servicio en todo el reino unido-
precisamente porque los que los
conducían eran migrantes que regresaron
a sus países y el reino unido- no tenía
como garantizar el combustible en muchas
ciudades de inglaterra y escocia en paso
preguntarle a francisco en la ciudad de
madrid' sobre la presión que puede haber
sobre la unión europea los organismos
internacionales la comunidad
internacional no está ejerciendo presión
sobre bruselas para para
y lograr
tener acciones un poco más concretas y
un poco más acertadas para este tema
europa va un poco a su aire
yo creo que si está viendo presiones
pero tal vez no suficientes desde el
inicio de la crisis en el año 2016 o del
agravamiento de la vuelva es decir de la
mal llamada crisis de refugiados el alto
comisionado internaciones unidas para
los refugiados
hizo muchos llamamientos y presionó
sobre muchos países para que
reconocieran a los demandantes de asilo
para que respetaran la convención del
año 51 y para que pusieran fin a los
sucesos que hubo en países como hungría
como chequia como como no como la propia
grecia luego de que hay trabajo tiene
que ser limitado en esas críticas porque
acnur recibe fondos de todos estos
países y yo creo que si han sucedido
cosas que no son muy muy conocidas pero
que sí conviene conocer como el que los
propios fondos de acción humanitaria de
la unión europea gestionados por la
comisión europea probé desde bruselas
que estaban pensados para crisis fuera
veterana europea han sido usados en una
gran medida para los campamentos en
grecia y otro tipo de medidas que no
entraban digamos en 700 tratados de gran
europea ni en el tratado de lisboa todos
los temas migratorios han afectado
gravemente y siguen afectando
a la política comunitaria pues en su
conjunto y como tú serías con tus
preguntas y las dos compañeras se decían
van
al margen de la razón porque muchos
economistas de mi propio país para
mantener la política de pensiones
hablan de que es necesario que
la trajera pero ahora son malos tiempos
como tú también lo querías del hilo de
las dos elecciones para que los países
los mandatarios que se presentan estas
elecciones que reconozcan este hecho y
ante el miedo del populismo o de la
extrema derecha que recurren a los temas
migratorios como la vuelven parte de esa
discurso de campaña está completamente
completamente pero bueno también hay que
reconocer que por parte de la ciudadanía
yo como utilizado en español veo en un
vídeo en ocasiones también con el
conocido concedido a torneo europeo
claro con mucha vergüenza
un retraimiento de las propias opiniones
públicas europeas en estos temas cosa
que no sucedía
los principios de siglo por supuesto
claro me quedan pocos minutos para
terminar el programa quiero que
terminemos hablando del tema de las
bandas de tráfico de personas que operan
en europa y en el norte de áfrica ya
conocemos los problemas que se han
presentado en varios países europeos
donde hay campamentos de personas que
están esperando intentando cruzar el
mediterráneo qué hacer con este fenómeno
europa le está prestando atención a este
fenómeno de las bandas además que muchos
de los migrantes que llegan pasan a
conformar estas mismas bandas para
reclutar más personas desde sus países
cuando uno mira la regulación en la
unión europea si alguien viene como para
acá pagando un traficante pero de todos
modos entonces dice que eso fue como una
situación de buena fe entonces y además
a lo antes posible' se reporta a las
autoridades no se puede discriminar en
frente de este refugiado inmigrante y
otro quien viene en otra forma entonces
pues a quien a quien estamos protegiendo
es siempre a refugiado en ese sentido
como que estas bandas de estas bandas si
uno mira y mira este tema lo que pasó
ahorita en valor rusia y lo que está
pasando de hecho de lucia en este
momento estas bandas ellos se reproducen
en diferentes países de ellos están en
varios países están en áfrica están en
el medio oriente están en europa porque
uno es como escoger narcotráfico uno
tiene que estar en todos lados para que
eso funcione
desafortunadamente pero hay algo muy
interesante lo que ahorita vemos en las
noticias con de loros ya como el
presidente en belorussia entonces se dio
cuenta que esta situación ya no está
funcionando tal cual y se devolvió
1.800 personas ayerra de hecho desde
hace a este momento casi se convirtió a
nulo las personas quienes están
aplicando en esta ruta lo que sería de
medio oriente belorrusia y buscando
hacia colonia entonces es un tema
supremamente difícil y pues mientras lo
quitaremos por ejemplo entre
sereno unido y francia- es gripe reino
unido paga 62 millones de euros para que
francia pues se mantenga pues a los
refugiados marino vamos a llegar hay que
cooperar y es el mensaje de macrón de
hecho si cooperación me queda un minuto
para el programa 20 segundos para cada
uno para la conclusión qué va a pasar
con este tema alexandra rápidamente
desafortunadamente no creo que como esté
encaminada a las cosas sucedan y
recordaré un antropólogo que hablaba de
cómo se da un fenómeno en el cual vamos
normalizando el sufrimiento ajeno verdad
en este momento son los choc a las 27
personas que acabaron de morir digamos
que ocupan todos los titulares pero
también sucedió hace un año hacia dos
años hace cinco años y se nos van
convirtiendo como parte del imaginario
llegarán las elecciones y las personas
votarán por el partido que más les venda
ese miedo que finalmente es el que nos
lleva a votar esa idea del extranjero
con el enemigo y seguirá un círculo
vicioso hasta que realmente una
autoridad internacional tenga el ánimo
de llevarnos en verdad a reivindicar
esos derechos humanos esta universalidad
estos derechos francisco 30 segundos
rápidamente su conclusión si yo creo que
claramente hay que recuperar ese ideas
que son las más racionales y además para
este tema como es el restablecimiento de
rutas legales que eviten este papel de
las mafias es muy fácil criticar a las
mafias es un mínimo común denominador
demasiado abajo todos estamos de acuerdo
en eso faltaría más
pero me parece que eso no resuelve los
problemas hay que
impulsar el establecimiento de estas
rutas
legales el establecimiento de cuotas
también en el ámbito europeo y el no
usar los mecanismos como el frontex de
una manera tan dura que en ocasiones y
en la pena canadiense decide entrar en
ese debate violan los derechos humanos
cedh francisco alexandra allí en madrid
y parís ya indicó aquí en el estudio
france24 les agradezco por haber hecho
este análisis para la audiencia de
france 24 ustedes pueden seguir dejando
sus comentarios y sus preguntas sigan
con nosotros
[Música]